you say kikuchi mike needless to say a
arm that uh has been rested up seven
days of rest for usa making his first
start against texas in 2020.
tavares digs in
he gets tavares to swing and ticket foul
back to taran's glove good start for you
say kakuchi strikes out the first man
that he sees dylan moore the batter just
off the injured list he had a wrist
problem one strike pitch and that ball
hammered
out to left field carrying back to the
wall white with a leaping catch at the
fence for out number two well that was
fun to see we had talked about eli white
today with chris woodward and you know
how he has adapted to the outfield he
was a college shortstop great athlete
and they have loved what they have seen
but he hasn't really got tested too much
yet at the big league level and here's
his first opportunity to go up and show
off that athleticism look how high he is
right fielder joey gallo will lay things
off here's a 2-2
swing and a miss strike three good
heater gallow down on strikes here's the
rangers catcher jose trevino
swaying and a miss strike three another
punch out for kikuchi already is third
that brings up ty france our first
chance to see him in a mariners uniform
he's dhing for scott service tonight
skimming past elvis andrews here comes
kyle seeger
throw coming home seeger slides and he's
safe nice start for ty france
tall left-handed hitting first baseman
ronald guzman heading at 421
swinging a miss for strength three
fourth strikeout for you say kikuchi
here's marmaleo so for one
the two two pits winging the ground ball
base it through the right side zigger to
third he's gonna be stopped there by
maniac to the throw home by the right
fielder joey gallo bases are loaded so
the bases are loaded for evan white the
stretch and the pitch on the way to
white swinging a well-hit ball deep to
left field white going back eli white
this one is off the wall seeger will
score right on his heels ty france will
score around to third goes marmaleo's
evan white into second base with a
two-run double the mariners with a
three-nothing lead over the rangers here
in the bottom of the fourth inning and
evan white hit a screaming mimi off the
wall in left field
right fielder joey gallo leading off the
top half of the fifth inning
swing and a miss by gallo for strike
three and that is strikeout number five
for you say kikuchi and counting trevino
the batter a strikeout victim is first
time
trevino hammers that ball out to left if
it stays fair it is gone
into that upper deck in left field a
solo shot for trevino his second home
run of the year
and it really does feel like when you
need a little bit of a boost you can get
it from jose trevino a guy who as you
mentioned the hitting has been there
he's doing a really nice job behind the
plate but he seems like he's been
starting to kind of slide into a little
bit of a leadership role it sure was the
pitch was up in the zone a fastball
maybe a cutter one out top of the fifth
that'll bring up designated shinsu
strike three called he rung him up
number six for kikuchi
hard hit seeger down to his chest picks
himself up the stretch and in time they
got him a masterpiece on both ends
tavares
strike three call 97 at the knees
seventh strikeout for you say kikuchi
the partners have a 3-1 lead over the
rangers new pitchers kendall graveman
coming out of the bullpen and
tip of the cap to usa kikuchi six strong
innings two hits one run it was earned
it was a home run by trevino
no walks seven strikeouts 89 pitches 52
for strikes rick that's one of the
better performances we've seen
how about some 97 on the inner black
gallo caught looking graveman off the il
retires his side in order
and haggerty hitting knight so they'll
turn the lineup over give crawford a
chance to drive in a run with two outs
out to right gallow galloping back got a
watching how about a three-run home run
j.p crawford blowing it open in the
eighth
you can hear it explode off the barrel
good looking shot there by j.p crawford
insurance requested insurance granted
six to one
[Music]
talked about it showing some pop on the
last road trip it was a good road trip
for him and here's a lazy little slider
in the middle of the plate at 83 miles
an hour
he barrels it up
[Music]
[Applause]
hitting 333 with an 833 ops
it's this ball sharply on the ground
that one through i say sharply
it snuck through into left field
another run is in it's 6-3 and how about
this the rangers get the tying run to
the plate in the ninth inning
counterfeit left at second gallow at
first
high chop
crawford has it
on the first ball game over the mariners
win they've won eight of the last 11.
but kikuchi was really good first game
back going six innings just two hits did
not walk anybody seven strikeouts they
had the one solo home run
j.p crawford with another home run
that's good to see good stuff mariners
take game one against the rangers